hey guys I'm rich Brian and today I'm
going undercover on the Internet it's
actually me seriously it's actually me
first up Twitter they got a tour right
right mix next recive said surely to God
they have to at eighty arising hear me
out head in the clouds festival but like
in the UK I would love that I would love
to go to the UK for an iPod Festival
that'd be tight I don't know where a lot
to disclose this but I think we might be
working on in the clouds in other places
hopefully I'm not gonna say anything
else hopefully in the UK one day I would
love that
next one y'all ever stop to think about
how much content there isn't Brian
driving and yet he does not have a
license care to explain rich Brian I
don't know if I'm legally allowed to
speak all this but you know who knows
what like what if it's a fake car and
whatever the fake green screen
background you never know you don't have
any evidence on me it's just a video I'm
gonna be effects and I'm good at editing
videos and photoshopping things so what
if I edited all that you don't know so
that's question what the [ __ ] cuz Andrew
yang on stage of rich Brian concert what
the [ __ ] that was a super random moment
I basically started my North American
tour and Riaan dance me he's like oh I
do you have a show tomorrow like are you
in town he was like maybe I should come
through and I was like oh yeah you
should you totally should
at one point he was like is it cold we
go on stage and I'm like yeah totally
absolutely so we gave him a mic he was
so excited it was so funny
it was crowd served at one point it was
super tight but yeah man super cool dude
and super random appearance but I think
people enjoyed it
hey Eddy arising I just wanted to know
who thought it was a good idea to give
my boy rich Brian that hair what do you
mean it was a good idea
I love the mullet dude that was a fake
moment that they just kind of like stuck
on my hair the glue was a stuck to my
hair for like the next three or four
days after that but I don't regret it
because it gave off such a powerful kind
of vibe and energy and I
to just like walk around with a bullet
all day I felt like session it felt
great you know I mean I appreciate those
who enjoyed it and those who don't like
it you're gonna like it one day just
keep an open mind can you make a rap
that details the steps to Rubik's cubes
actually it's not one it's actually not
a terrible idea
I would love to make like a TJX textile
rap about solving a Rubik's Cube
so thank you for that idea I might come
out with that one day and I wait you up
for your royalties Oh Instagram all
right
Brian and Jayden collab soon I don't
know
Jayden do you want to collab I would
love to collab with Jayden he's a lot
busier than I am he's out there fixing
the world and you know having free vegan
food trucks and [ __ ] shout-out to him
he's great
it's he on the toilet yep he's on the
toilet I was in on the toilet and I was
taking a [ __ ] and then I was like this
could be you know good content and I've
been posting on Instagram for a while so
I'm gonna take a picture of this I was
on my way to Japan with my parents and
when I took this picture my mom was
actually waiting outside of the bathroom
for me yeah I'm really proud of this one
Quora
you may not believe it but it's actually
me how did rich Brian get famous I got
famous for my dick pics and I'm just
kidding no I kind of got a following
online on Twitter I would say but then
it really started popping out when I
started making music when I was 16 it's
been a crazy ride since then I found
idiot rising the label that I'm with
before actually meeting them I was in
Indonesia and then I was just like
working with them remotely on skype and
I finally came to America when I was 17
and at the first show in America that it
was rolling loud Miami which was insane
very unforgettable experience and it's
been a crazy ride so that's not gonna
finish submit what are the best rich
Bryant sauce I really like to drive safe
from the Sailor that's like a good
singing song you like that if you like
rap songs I would recommend kids if you
don't know much about me it's one of my
lyrical songs and like is
very kind of like it's the storytelling
song about just kind of everything that
happened to me then just everything like
that I went through I look vacant
I feel like people sleep on vacant it's
a song about a failed relationship about
a girl that's very insecure and then the
dude is just like dude I'm just trying
to treat you nice and like you're making
all these accusations and it's making me
feel like I'm a piece of [ __ ] and in the
middle of it I start singing in falsetto
so what more can you ask for submit next
one Wikipedia Brian was home schooled in
has stated that he does not wish to seek
college education though if given a
chance he would attend film school
you're right you're right it's just too
late for me I was home-schooled and I'm
academically just like I missed out on
like so many years of school that if I
went to college I would not know to do
and also just the whole idea of just
like going to college and like drama
bully and I feel like people would bully
me they're like having homework that
sucks I'm sorry
and having a teacher having a teachers
is such a strange concept to me at this
point because I'm so used to just like
learning things on YouTube
Megan the stallion is out there just
like being a very successful rapper and
just like going to college at the same
time and there are multiple artists that
do this I salute them for doing it I
can't I cannot do that posted ready why
is an idiot rising popular in Southeast
Asia is it hot I feel like it is I don't
know there's a like a statistic or a
number anything but I feel like it is
starting to be Alize idiot rising had
guessed it a collaboration and then I
did a photo shoot with them they put a
picture I mean like super big and all
the storefronts and like all the
Southeast Asia but the picture is like
super ugly I did this like super ugly
awkward pose and I didn't know that they
were gonna put it up in the store
friends I thought it was gonna be like a
fun online thing that everybody was
gonna pose and then I found out that it
was basically all over Southeast Asia so
it's so good so good honest question who
exactly are these rappers we're going
after Brian do I talk about that a lot
is that something that I talk about of
my songs did I say that
I guess I don't know rappers are very
competitive
everybody just feels like we gotta prove
themselves and like be aggressive to
everybody but at the same time I'm
friends with some really nice rappers
and we're actually all cool with each
other this is all fake we're not out
here just trying to kill each other and
just trying to like finish each other's
careers and whatever maybe some rappers
talk [ __ ] about other rappers it's all
fake
you know everybody's bullshitting and
this is all Hollywood posted YouTube I
bro no one's gonna talk about the fact
that this girl started drinking blue at
1:30 yeah she started drinking blue and
then we were like yo let's get that it
was super tight it was not real well no
kids were hung so Sam we said is no I'm
gonna comment about the fact that he
just up and has a freaking pet crocodile
yeah I'm not sure how many people think
that is a fake crocodile but who's a
real crocodile it was actually like a
full-grown like five year old crocodile
but it was just the type of crocodile it
was like a really small one it was
terrifying it was just like I was just
holding it the whole time in the
crocodiles mouths was like just open the
whole time and then just kind of like
staring into nothingness just kind of
like and I was like the whole time I'm
holding out I'm like I wonder what he's
thinking about and then the guy that
like the animal instructor he was like
their brains are really small like that
so most of the time they're not thinking
about anything so I'm like wow that was
nice i j CT said it's only me or there
is a tons of references to the beatles
in the song i would say so i know what
you're talking about
they can work on this song a lot and
then you know i know he's like a huge
Beatles fan so I'm sure that's where it
came from and you know the way the
vocals are layered and like harmony
isn't everything it's definitely feels
posted all right everybody thank you so
much for your questions this has been
rich Brian and I'm signing off the
internet